was there an opportunity for you to come
back on the view at any point know that
you know they I think we all agreed that
the last time that it was better for
everyone you know Whoopi really didn't
like me explain it to me I was assuming
that I was coming in to be part of an
ensemble right throw the ball back and
forth everybody shoot everybody take a
shot right and from day one she was
upset with like I threw to commercial
because I didn't know that she saw a
countdown the guy was like going like
this
now listen she's been there forever
maybe that's normal and she does
I saw the and I and there was a pause
and I said we'll be right back after
this and you know that was the first day
and then there was trouble from then on
in other words it was perceived that you
were trying to make it the Rosie
O'Donnell show and Whoopi was like Oh
Rosie's not playing ball I know that she
thought she liked it how it was and I
mean we were friends in the celebrity
vernacular for a long time sure yeah
when I went to do that show I went to
her house and talked to her you know we
had a great sort of come-to-jesus I said
listen I only want to do this if you
want me to do this with you I was
thinking we were gonna be like you know
Scottie Pippen and Michael Jordan like
oh you know like that it was gonna be
the greatest thing of all time to me
even when I saw that you went on and
Whoopi was on I would say those are two
alphas they're too similar
they have both outspoken political views
you hire Rosie she's the leader that's
it yeah never could have worked we
either had to be you or Whoopi you know
we bumped into each other Howard does
the story you would like I would love
this I went to see Bagan Mullally and
her husband's band at the I think cafe
Carlyle and I was meeting Ally Sheedy
there and so she wasn't there yet so I
get out of my limo and I'm walking into
the venue I see another SUV pull up and
I thought to myself I wonder who that is
or and I go into the venue and I turn
around and who's standing right next to
me what we go over well I go hi you know
she's like oh hey I was so nice right
so kind of effusive then the maitre d
came over and said oh he's so done a
table for two come over this foot I'm
like no no no we're not sitting together
and what we said would it be that bad
that's and I was like no I'm just I'm
meeting someone sure you are too when
good to see you you know
but it was like that awkward horrible
yeah well look you said she was his mean
to you as anyone had ever been she was
mean to me on live TV when people say
well what happened I say go back and
watch them it's not like a mystery
watched the way it went down and I don't
need to say anything I mean did it hurt
my feelings tremendously
it was trippy to me but I knew I had to
leave so I was like I got to get out of
here I can't do this I'm not fighting
with Whoopi Goldberg I have no desire to
fight with her